We will be very sad very narrow right. John.
But I mean I'm sure that happens if you use that language once more but my wife
and I have my you know that very very much in a situation where they should be having fun
and I was on the other hand that it is time to eat a cookie films of well known he was really you know there's no
question he would love to write for us and be right to write while we write. He was sending him to the world.
He was born at home he was really interested.
He was house where he would say when I was interested in what they had to sexually or not
but I did think that he really so sexually with me that a very good bit of a simply world present well I don't even
know whether it was because you know he wasn't at all and I think one reason.
Most of it was actually never something to have sex with a major nation
but I think it was trying to establish that you're right there are probably some people who are right for a few years
when they are status and he's merely a Lavery yet it was a terrible he had a terrible.
I wish I was on holiday on time just consciousness we have so much wrong with me
but are usually a lot of us love as well as I used to go through. I need to get in rushes with me.
That is the thing and I'll be out for all you guys and never seem to include any all out war.
Here he would be interested in anybody who was trying to bring somebody here
and it wouldn't matter if they were eighty five or sixty or if they were for you.
He even knew the symptoms of money never got it right that right by the way they know very well that I have any money
and would like to play them
and he was interested in never never in a situation where you know that because then you have to get his vote again.
Otherwise he's get tell you coming after you tell me if he was trying. The slightest bit interested. He got me.
Well I remember it was going to play this way since I was one of those yellow have seen as it was as if he was.
And you know I was going to back up against the wall
and then eventually you consider yourself Where will you consider the mishandling was when he
when he tired of telling delegates to get into Paris.
I will look it's not it that they have said that was when we were in London. We've seen a lot of quite a few months.
Countless nights are doing what we must we must get there. Harris have a look at you know how to be homeless.
Why just ran out
and I said let's set a date if we put a date said oldest which if I had really wished my leg was a bit scared. Oh.
First of all night. I'm trying to have money not just I was trying to get a job in the theater.
He was more or less trying to get a job in the theater on my own he was still really it was a process that he had
and I would have stuck it all and not a great deal of interest in it
but he used to just write it so you know the just because you can get rid of it in the street that you're a prostitute.
I had taken so I used to do that a lot Johns around the place you know I'm sorry I was saving up for the cameras you
know but I got right now you got to say I did with both got to have the same amount of money you can
and take a small amount of the city on that plane which was a fortune to become a pretty Countess
and I was just trying to she said I recently learned that we were hitchhiking out of the way we were very trying to get
only there a way we charged down by which I mean between lists with Cal because they were going to get that I was like
Drop us a bit you know they are teaching. Yes. And you're on the right and I say do it now. I said I'll get right down.
I said I got exactly how much of you got he said I'm not quite that much.
My mother how much I've got but I have often the very bottom line you is usually here.
My children will be up to date we have to get through immigration.
Here is your house
and the customs at that particular time investigating how much money we're taking you know he said to me how much money
you got the critical trade and you write. You know on the phone and he said John Wright how much of you John.
Rosen and I ten ten years. He's old enough to not only not tell you sir. He said.
Surely you know what his hate to say didn't do it
and he was terrified that was another case which everybody had handed out there at him.
Shyly maintained their usual little brother loved it usually so the Customs man said How long do you intend staying
and how this said trying to rise above the situation said Oh in this.
I'm so I jumped to the best but I do get a little weak. I said my my trade you broke up like it was a little let it go.
You couldn't have got a little bit.
So the crowd here is usually here or maybe the lady had the most of it
or not it was jamming out there now like twenty two. You are painting which I did before.
Yes I know tell me something funny and we can do a sightseeing.
All right so we went where we slept all day and went to the club which was just under fifty years.
Let's face it and I was very different.
The next five years with John commentary would you believe I mean it sounds right.
Living with it was a piece of shit sort of and I can hear you see in those days.
He's like a lot of the period which was a sort of a list of what was there which was great.
Whether you could say there was in the room you call this a you know I don't know I didn't know it well.
Well there I place together there was a verse of that which just off the sounds of the say the rest of the lives of the
right and then to go was.
And that was the festival which was getting a purely and simply gay and it's still running still Gary.
But you just expensive now. Gee station here.
We used to walk in and buy one of the song Take it to the table set of the tables
and I had a great big plate of nuts on a site that was out there
and we just we did eat our way through that it's not like we've moved to another title but need all of that time.
The last time I was in Paris.
I was in for the routine probably the best of our short life there so I thought we're like everyone always tired Gary
and I still that's a strange thing with me if I'm on my own I'm still in the greatest various places like what she
could get carried on for a particular project that he had thought he had back in her region but I still don't.
And I was right to say that or seriously just gas prices you know sort of the ice at night and I thank you very much.
It is the price to get it just over probably a little bit just over there so that you know like you like the idea was
that this is this is all this is all this is laid away just yet that's how I was remember a time
when I was at the cross and I was down I was really about twenty five.
And I was like oh well it was Russia all come out now what we were talking about all of Europe was all about.
We're talking about we're talking about we're talking about the early fifty's
and I was at the section of the cross the that is that cross section right where the valley is now you know not now not
because for sexual abuse to be called Person point it's to call that pension point.
And they used to be a place called the hasty tasty.
You know good old dark place which was unique across in most places we're not over twenty four hours a best way to get
most places enough to tasty used to be saying I'm going to show it was to me the rocky side was on the path.
So this is wrong smelly potential.
Well I never said I was under that smell like and that's exactly what the rock inside was saddled rotten past the hour.
While it sounds good. Although not have subsided was a man decides when you know you're beautiful.
This is a very different side of this one that uniform I don't know you got distinction no problem with whether we
should just we're sure he was around that area and it was about night it was light.
About nine o'clock at night
and also this most divine looking Nordic type of Swedish body just the most divine ritual I just I just don't think gas
at his elbow on the on the. Tram stop was a training program running for President Reagan. Yes that's right.
And I saw him and he got on the train partly because he got on the track. I don't know where I was Gary.
But I just followed the man just got off the track and he got off the track. So I got off to an interesting heritage.
But I got off the track and he went up one side street and I followed them.
I mean I was a bit six inches shorter than a great big creature he went to the sideline turned quite deliberately in
the doorway.
So when I came up I had to come straight up to him
and he said Oh I see you are interested in this I think you said it will cost you money.
I said Oh you are but not never had any one citation may cost you money
and people to the occasion said Oh I said Hold on.
Sorry I said I do thank you very much something stupid like that
and I just went off like that because I have to because he was going to want to go off as he was destroying you know
his I think he sounded nice so that was my first introduction to somebody who directly asked me to be any other kind of
people that actually asked me for money but people with life took her it's a rough try that on my life taken me.
It's really more like on a street just Raftery in the street.
See here across the years around that area across like Gary I used to.
I used to like tell me there was a train with no train
and I thought I haven't seen anything before because that's really quick.
Victoria was generally what it was like straight and NOT NOT NOT NOT rough trade in the pick up.
I can show where people.
Where it was mostly only all you get there once or twice
but I was never going to try to get your sight back to where the sailors.
Places in which three dollars raised by the place still live.
It's the final label house he shot her all her life a lot of people some people I know with two Richard B.
Of the street that I got was he going down that direction in his father's rough rough right old bisexual
or he was actually the man is all over the world. You know they're all the possibility.
Yeah you know although the possibility of a lot more danger into it
but I really really had people you know it was fall out.
Yes legacy was going to follow this for years because some people make sure that first of all I think people thought
they had some sort of reputation as a place you're right about with you right.
Well across the Cross facility a place a very early forty years particularly I think people went to become a phony
or coffee shop across that or it's above where the price tree. It was upstairs was a lamp was on the ground zero.
There was not stairs area.
It's not a strip joint downstairs downstairs here but it was the kind of corner Martin that stayed.
It was just a little it was a coffee shop a little bit on the street level and then regular.
About a strong place for really dark history on the left hand side of the front here several joint places.
I think it's possible to where the hotel is the only place where I don't know.
Someone was staring all those days when they but there are also a lot of people here which is also rather similar
or rather sort of like the nearly four year for fifteen years before they would play there was the Kashmir coffee shop
around the corner
and Russell liked to play for one of the sons of the woman that was in the place replaceable trophies
and he had me in Saudi Arabia of the by his mother single shop next door. Like I said right here.
I don't use the cards enough answers because you might write your life
and that was a very very very very procedural very strange run through the end of this of this road where a lot of
people looking back on it's probably pretty true.
Or does it feel like things are as you see in those days the in the right way. Right.
But here we have a very very very unlikely place with nothing to do you guarantee a person I mean are we going to get a
Yes hello.
Yes you're right it probably was a little more action and you know you just take that for you know roughly three three.
But what about the director of writing for sexual director just comparing the percentage of him here is the impression
that people might find out about and any of the other.
From my own inclinations around the school and everything I've noticed out here that just great.
Oh I thought I'd like to raise attention with anybody who was actually wasn't even talked about
or read about in my school night the references to it
but very oblique he didn't just ask you if you have thought about it.
I just find some of these cranks straight to the guys on the roster at school of high round.
We never told about the largest of our well I even got the most of out of but that's just one means of expression
and I just didn't think of this particularly as I have to say but what I was actually as well.
With this thread were well I wouldn't have married
and there's days not that I went to school I was not like down with people running around
and two of them got it clear all year round but with no camp actually it was a narrow your me
but as far as a perceptual join these are just sort of schoolyard slide. Yet I don't think that was either.
It was like any other when I was younger I used to call me girly at school I love it.
That's a good deal because this year old girl appeared.
That's a good early early to let me get off of things very quickly because all right you're to spend all my time with a
very cold rage.
We used to be having it off when I was in grade play Try it for you guys before you tell them off
and they're pulling each other off the kids seem to that they've got a name like.
I've never heard of anybody actually seen me every day was a regular thing I think I'll arrange for you.
Like you wouldn't do for the play each other.
Yeah that was all just messed amazingly messed up but yes I needed that state. I don't know about.
And you know I think the other day here I was on that day.
Jerry I was very struck and there is a good possibility that for quite a while
when I was about thirty first a parable of sexually aware for three fifteen over a baby that even later I thought the
natural way great thing in laboratories
and things like public buildings people would travel around the ready for the areas we used to mother used to go to so
we have to go by trying to come by an unknown.
They used to be this profanity
and then what really fascinated me was to where it gets used to be one of the most popular graffiti is that you see
when you look around what you're just going to get leverage yourself like fax me an invisible hand
and the fact that between a man and a woman was when I put up a woman's bottom line here
and I thought the right of the other way for quite some time to grow thirty forty but I don't know
when we really are beginning to my mother about sixteen before somebody pointed out to me at the right whether
or not just come about because I used to see this big things of stories of right. And so on. So right. You soon.
Right for the more exciting you know from the front that's the front because it's the public toilets have a view of the
hills around the idea of the fucking pole.
You see one of the other things which nothing about the things about when they really think about things like
when they had a front on each other. I mean there was a very very guilty about what I was doing three towns away.
All I can remember of that word for about four days. That really was trying to.
Really when different money or a little bit of it.
Listening to something like a public toilet
or carry just to get help to have a straw in front of me right behind the very or I do it in pictures
and believe anyone approached me around here didn't have sexual experience with no injury to find out about what I
found out to be a part should we be here. Spiritually.
Apart from severe measures like that and they were very early days.
Very nice guy Grant me your area back or somewhere I can make you sick of approaches and I didn't my mouth
or the stomach from that time without my right.
So that was probably because I didn't get really affected types I really think it probably was just the song This is
the thing with me I was always approached by older people always found it very obvious.
Somehow because I was eventually approached by someone that I thought reasonably attractive
but later that I met through. Again. RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT RIGHT.
Carol phone they are like he put me in the Cold War I was really attracted to people like what you just physically
because this is your life.
Think of the rivers of blood probably a lot less of a Christian one person think it was right because every college is
a great deal and how to play cricket you have to be good at cricket
and if you're good at this that in the way that you really have to be for the popular viewpoint to begin to express an
opinion because Dr Norman here who used to write.
He had a regular weekly column for I was actually discovered there was an actor.
I was I was reading out from e Bay for a lot of years. You met the man.
Come back come back till he came back because he was terrified to come right for me. I mean that particular.
Public already pretty low. Right.
Still someone is manning this young man with his shirt on the chair sort of right down there is here which is about as
direct as you get in those days I just have the strongest hot flash in the world of your do you have your picture of
the story in light of what is it about this race for a lot of people not to middle class.
People actually don't think I mean people who are people like you know about their first novel that I read that really
presented a bang on the first here not you know not here was a particular part of the story where the other woman on
the mouth.
It had an effect on the production of the play which was the first time that I think being treated very
straightforwardly as a long taken from you because in the first act a lot of production in this extraordinary character
wrote quite.
You know he was an actor and he used to do the radio work
but I know because I had access to two radio things at that time radio producer for a time traveler to do with
commercial radio but people were much of course at that time in the profession number of leading radio like.
They were discreet and somewhat like bisexual. Much more. I mean much.
I mean obviously part of it seems to me that even going back in the sixty's was much more much. He said about. Right.
People here in the global war. But polish the trip to Brazil.
That you do the same here yet looking in here you are going to try to you know we can later be over here I just thought
oh my God he's my husband but I mean that you. I've got some of that down.
Have you thought of what we're big sign here is a good way of getting more with us
and the risk to really be feasibly can be far more. There's a war.
Just because they understand that you are willing to share their stories you just go back a story from the book you
will know they're right here. He's the guy that was a recently and very cheap prices because the receipts.
Here was never made with it. There was a question there we all said we were friends today. Oh right yeah yeah yeah.
So it's all done so we end up. That is something I just wrote The Rev Wright.
Yeah right up to the end of the runway I thought was waiting for true love a real word this guy here is in your way
very sorry but like I really really great residential area every day here in Boston last night which scenes are more
or less just nice he takes you around the area with the pick up area.
You literally see standing on the corner you watch his standing on the court just just wait right here.
I never really know you're not sure exactly where there is a very deep right.
This is one of the Russian rows with something like a Range Rover there were letters which are going to get you around
which I should have run off with a boy or look where your great heart is father quite a story.
It was literally straight.
You gave me with that life finally from there was sort of walk around like you're sixty we're actually you guys did
just that right there disappear completely understood what I mean basically or just as if you either.
Never a good job right now
or years highlight will be very very rough for I'm sure you will realize this is the influence of the man who was with
us. But if you wake up you got another cat right here.
Well now you if you want to do that you may enjoy life British racing
or of the cross you wear from well over the Harris County which is down there though you're down there you know the
place straight will with you and because that dark dark street below right. Which is right.
You're going round has every following of the line culture war for you we're talking about you said that you think it
was in the front that there was this was their man. JON STEWART Yes Richard.
This is really just the part to really hear.
Oh yes that was George Bush and the first time wall
and I'm with you especially yesterday about oh joy out of this jury if you're George leg. All right. What was wrong.
Is not really very good here.
It was really it was you know not just share the rescission out there like you know as long as I was aware it was all
about a rush. You know send me to a place the shares were a place to go.
I was here it was a big part of the whole area probably close close to a lot of music shops.
You know very like certainly like here like you know. It will be. Really doing that.
I know I've been so busy trying to be here while he's right there on the road a lot like most of us here you have to
get your child from your place to your swimming cost you something which you don't think you're enough if you really
you know you get by the way if you do you get to get caught
and you can hear if you close your own you change your look
but always there you will leave here with me because you get up here about.
I'm sure the usual kind of the late you mean you should you trust and I sure do.
And then
when you've got drummed out of each year you have to change your route to jail usually because you're so good that
sometimes you live in the Sunday Mirror this is all the more you everyone will lie there without any further on that.
Oh yeah well this happened. Our own relationships a good. Oh yeah.
Are you sure you know how to rock and roll over the years and China Russia. Maybe earlier than that but not. All right.
But I don't think that many people get their drugs and how they will get into the new year.
Here are those sure you're going to find these simple things like Chinese in public like Chinese
or the six o'clock truck really strong. Oh really good.
You see I always do beef this friend of mine who has a drug which you can actually see you know that from the I can
tell you I just am not coming out of the stock cars right straight
and we guessed right from there to this right along this is twenty five to six this night that the earliest we have
well I drink a lot of memory
but there was some people were told you had the only time you had three very five to six for maybe all five of us
probably like you know five or six o'clock to pick up someone.
Oh my goodness you guys are broken hearted that night more likely the younger crowd here we go for a little somewhere
your way to the view. This year.
Yes Let me let me know
when you Google what you just said have you said you should start right there yet it was the year I was in the audience
the one hundred. Because of your small place like Florida you draw a very good meal here and I see tarragon here.
This is a good course he'll be getting but not from the right from the letters
and really really well there really was a new relationship you made your life was a loss of life
but the rest of what was wrong with it was delicious.
But this is not all this is that's just a little scary and you're very very little bit more about this newsgroup.
Gary and our lives let's forget our mother's life.
No not really sad is your goal is this here is a list of services
and it will seem really just sorry bro I can tell you as I said I joined up with that they should try to rewrite it
and it was like a garrison city.
You know I needed to run a really heavy duty free device right here with me right there right.
We were hit by golly some good old trial by the army general market right here. You never changes.
They are and all the rest wrong had been you made into it
but you know you're interesting about all those sort of a very vicious and so I was up there
and what was this little guy.